devil fruits the ultimate power system
in one piece and today we're going to
talk about every single devil fruit that
has officially appeared in the series so
far based on the manga starting with all
Zone type devil fruits now this category
of fruits allows the user to transform
into an animal granting them immense
strength and stamina and depending on
the fruit some unique bonus abilities as
well and at number one we have a pretty
straightforward transformation Dalton
the king of the Sakura Kingdom uses his
ushi ushinomi model bison to turn into a
bison Kaku of cp9 on the other hand uses
his fruit to turn into a giraffe now
you'd think this would be a useless
power but using his long neck as a
counterbalance he actually uses his
transformation to enhance his
swordsmanship not really sure why it's
categorized as a cow fruit though but as
you'll see a few of the fruits don't
really make sense now what's better than
turning into a cow well turning into a
human being Chopper is a reindeer who
ate the hitohistonomi the human human
fruit presumably this fruit would be
absolutely useless if an actual human
aided or if the SPs is to be believed
they might gain Enlightenment but in
Chopper's case he gained the ability to
walk talk and have human intellect on
the other hand the former Fleet admiral
of the Marine sengoku uses the dibu to
through to transform into a giant Golden
Buddha making for a very intimidating
presence on the battlefields and
sticking with Japanese mythology onimaru
is a komagitsune a type of mythical Fox
however this is unrelated to his devil
fruit the onyudo fruit allows onimaru to
transform into onyudel a type of giant
monk Yokai and like Chopper this fruit
grants onimaru the ability to speak and
well what do you know were only six
fruits in and we've already gotten to
our main character now for years Oda led
us to believe that Luffy had the
gomugomonomi but in reality his fruit
was actually the hito hitonomi model
Nika this fruit for instance grants
Luffy the powers of the sun god Nika
nicknamed The Tune Force by the fandom
which are seemingly only limited by
Luffy's own imagination bending reality
to his will and the most powerful human
type devil fruit is of course none other
than the subscriber subscriber no me
eaten by you dear viewer after you
destroyed the Subscribe button below
this video next we have all the birds
Pell one of Princess vivi's Guardians in
Alabaster can transform into a falcon
allowing for super fast flights his
hybrid 4 makes Pell look like Horus the
falcon-headed god of Egyptian mythology
the jury is still out on whether Falcons
can actually withstand nuclear weapons
though like Pell apparently did at the
end of the alabaster Arc one of the
coolest fruits in the entire series is
Marco's Phoenix fruit whitebeard's first
division Commander Marco is also the
doctor of the crew which works
fantastically because the Phoenix fruit
Flames allow him to heal himself and
others and interestingly enough for some
reason big news Morgans who always keeps
up his hybrid Albatross Forum cannot fly
ironic given that the real world
Albatross are known for their extremely
long flights across the sea so good
thing he has those new schools to
deliver the papers for him moving on to
men's best friends and all the doggos
starting with lasso of Baroque Works who
is not a dog who ate a cannon fruit he's
actually a cannon who was fed the Ino
inonomi model daksuns this character was
actually the very first instance of
learning that inanimate objects like a
cannon could be fed devil fruits Chaka
is the other Zone guardian of alabaster
his chical hybrid form makes him look
like the Egyptian god Anubis who also
has a jackal for a hit Jabra of zp9 uses
his devil fruit to transform into a
giant powerful wolf in addition he loves
using trickery and storytelling to try
and fool his victims calling upon the
many fairy tales would feature a big bad
wolf such as the three little piggies or
Little Red Riding hoods and we have yet
another inanimate object with a devil
fruit bambuku is a teapot who ate a
Tanuki fruit Katarina Devon is one of
Blackbeard's crewmates and with her
Kitsune mythical Zone fruit she can
transform her appearance to appear as
any other person she wants to pretty
convenient meanwhile Yamato kaido-san
has a mythical wolf Zone fruit that
transforms them into the okochinomakami
The Protector deity of wano who also
possesses ice-based powers and it really
looks just stunning and of course after
dogs we have to talk about cats Luchi
the PowerHouse of zp9 uses his leper
transformation to gain immense strength
dexterity and Agility meanwhile who's
who a former member of dp9 fits right in
with the Beast pirates with his
saber-toothed tiger Zone like many of
his crewmates his ancient devil fruit is
based on an already extinct animal which
now brings us to two elephant fruits yet
another inanimate object with the devil
fruit power is Funk freed a sword who
can transform into an extremely cute
looking elephant I mean just look at
those eyes and really on the complete
opposite side of the cuteness spectrum
is Jack one of kaido's All-Stars who is
a Fishman who has eaten the mammoth
devil fruit not so cute and for some
people this next one is definitely the
best category of animals to turn into
dinosaurs now don't get it twisted Drake
here is not a T-Rex he's an Allosaurus
and according to paleontologists those
are two very different dinosaurs
interestingly enough like all of the
other dinosaur fruits to come on this
list this fruit is categorized as the
view you fruit which means Dragon not
dinosaur page one Spinosaurus fruit is
yet another powerful dinosaur
transformation from one of the Toby Ropo
the paternidon fruit of the All-Star
King is modeled after a flying dinosaur
significantly larger than the
pterodactyl now the most significant
power that King's fruit gives him is
flight however oda's Mastery of biology
teaches us that they are also able to
use their large crests and beaks in a
slingshot effect to utilize ranged
attacks as well apparently meanwhile
Queen the last of kaido's commanders
we're covering has a Brachiosaurus
fruits and yet again we got a science
lesson from Oda that states that
brachiosauruses can apparently launch
their long necks and tail from the rest
of their body to become a sort of
snake-like creature and the manga makes
this very clear that this is not one of
Queen's many cybernetic enhancements but
a natural born ability of
brachiosauruses so I guess learn
something new here then we have ulti one
of the flying six who has a very fitting
dinosaur Zone transformation as well the
Pachycephalosaurus literally means
thick-headed lizard boasting a skull
several times thicker than any other
dinosaur makes sense for the most
stubborn and hard-headed of kaido's crew
I guess and the last of our dinosaur
fruits is sazaki's model triceratops and
during Frankie's fight against the
flying six we get yet another
paleontology lesson when we learn the
Triceratops Frills can actually spin
around like a propeller enabling them to
fly which brings me to snakes also
reptiles and also quite terrifying here
we have marigold holds king cobra fruit
as well as sandersonas Anaconda fruit
both of these boa sisters have snake
Transformations which is very fitting
for siblings based on the famous Gorgon
sisters of Greek mythology and yet
another hippie hibinomi model for
mythology is the Orochi fruit held by
well Orochi this member of the kuruzumi
clan really lucked out on finding a
devil fruit that shared his literal name
this one allows him to transform into
the eight-headed snake the Yamato Orochi
its bonus effect is that all of his
heads have to be removed for him to be
killed which did lead to not one but
nine very satisfying decapitations in
the wano arc this here is smiley a
weaponized gas cloud given life in form
of an axoloti upon its destruction we
learned that a devil fruit reincarnates
into another normal fruit nearby upon
its user's death and interestingly
enough there are only three insect devil
fruits in one piece so far Mushi is
Japanese for buck and these two buck
fruits are owned by Warriors of the
tomtada first of Kabul with the Kabuto
fruit and then beyond with the Hornet
fruit oh and yeah this one is very
ironic because kaido's actual dragon
fruit is not a dragon fruit but an fruit
a fish fish fruit his fruit is derived
from the Japanese myth of a carp jumping
over a waterfall to transform into a
dragon think the Magikarp to Gyarados
transformation from Pokemon seryu or the
Azure dragon is also one of the four
sacred beasts of Chinese astrology
joined by the White Tiger the red
Phoenix and the black turtis this is the
third insect fruit black Maria seems to
have more in common with a black widow
spider really than the graphogel one
however the growl Fogle is an ancient
extinct spider which makes this fruit
fit in a lot better with the other
already extinct creatures of the Beast
Pirates the rest of our Zone fruits here
are single model fruits that have only a
single member or the actual fruit names
are still unknown starting off the list
is Miss Merry Christmas of Baroque Works
who can transform into a mole then we
have Pierre a large pink bird who ate a
horse fruit this enabled Pierre to
transform into an approximation of a
Pegasus hecams is a lion mink who can
transform into a turtle hell yeah Baron
tamago has one of the more interesting
Zone devil fruits he begins as an egg
not like Dr Robotnik just a man in a
shell I guess however he can transform
into a fully developed egg and become a
full-blown chicken the imple down
jailers all have what are referred to as
awakened zones they end up losing their
higher functions and turn into
simple-minded rampaging beasts with
immense strength they are a Minotaur
presumably with another cow devil fruit
a koala a rhino and a zebra and these
four are actually contenders for the
very first awakened devil fruits that we
ever get to see in the series unless we
count Choppers monster point which is
currently unconfirmed as a devil fruit
Awakening oh by the way did I say three
insects well I did lie there are two
more actually vice admiral onigumo of
the Marines has an unknown devil fruit
that allows him to grow several
spider-like arms and his name is also
the Japanese name of a variety of
spiders meanwhile vice admiral Dalmatian
also has a very on the nose name as his
current unnamed devil fruit allows him
to transform into a Dalmatian and the
last insect fruit that also appears
during the Marine Ford war is ipoida an
ally of Whitebeard who can transform
into a caterpillar with this unnamed
Zone devil fruit then in a cover story
detailing what happened in imple down
after the prison break we meet the
newest Jailer an adorable Mino Chihuahua
and the latest Zone devil fruit that
we've gotten is stronger duck Q's horse
who ate a pegasus mythical Zone to gain
Wings I'm gonna guess that he'd get
along pretty great with Pierre the other
Pegasus in the series and while that is
all of the zones in the series but we
are just getting started because up next
is the Loya category now these fruits
allow users to turn into an element as
well as general great seemingly
Limitless amounts of it and the very
first logo that we meet in the series
was smoker the white Hunter a prominent
marine and rival to Luffy as his name
suggests he is able to turn into smoke
and really he was the perfect first
opponent to demonstrate this incredibly
useful devil fruit power meanwhile the
first warlord that the straw had faced
off against was crocodile owner of the
sandlokia not only could crocodile use
his sand to release powerful attacks
like Espada but he also had the ability
to drain the moisture out of anything
rendering his opponents into dry husks
however Luffy found that crocodile was
weak to water and by drenching his hands
he could actually land blows against the
Warlords Luffy's brother Ace wielded the
flame flame fruit or the mira mira Nomi
now this fruit was a major plot point in
dressrosa when though Flamingo offered
it as a prize in the Colosseum to bait
Luffy in this tournament Luffy and Ace's
other brother Sabo finally ended up
claiming the fruits meanwhile Eno has
one of the most powerful Logan of fruits
we've ever seen in a series in addition
to the usual lightning based Powers we
see him striking from an extremely long
range using his electricity to power
technology manipulate metals and even
restart his own heart it was just a
little bit unfortunate for him that a
robbery man ended up showing up in
skypea kuzan's ice root is one of the
few devil fruits we've seen that can
clearly impact sea water despite the sea
being a devil fruit user's weakness by
freezing the surface of the ocean he's
able to bicycle from Islands to Island
pretty convenient he can also freeze
opponents inside and out and they can be
shattered to pieces if not carefully
heated up Blackbeard meanwhile has one
of the most unusual logias to the point
where we're wondering if it's not
actually a Zone fruit the Yami Yami Nomi
or the darkness fruits rather than his
body Turning Into Darkness he can suck
matter into a black hole Blackbeard is
also a lot more vulnerable to pain and
can nullify the fruit powers of other
devil fruit users that he touches
borsolino another Marine Admiral uses
the Pika pikanomi the light lokia fruit
using his devil fruit he can deliver
light speed kicks and fly from Island to
Island faster than any ship can actually
travel Dr vegapunk also used this fruit
as the basis for developing the passy
feast as beam lasers and zakazuki the
current Fleet Admiral wields the magma
fruit its immense power Burns much
harder than the fire fruit which made it
possible for him to kill Ace during the
marineford war this is one of the most
offensively powerful fruits in the
entire series oh and then we have karibu
another very unique logia fruit user
like Blackbeard whose fruit doesn't
allow the typical logia rules his swamp
doesn't seem to be able to generate
Limitless amounts of muck but he does
have a seemingly Limitless storage
inside of himself inside of this swampy
pocket Dimension he can store plenty of
meat or even mermaids Caesar Clown's gas
fruit has dominion over an entire state
of matter he's able to create various
gases usually poisonous ones but he can
also remove the oxygen in a given area
to suffocate opponents Monet a member of
the doflamingo family has a snow snow
fruit this is a fairly straightforward
logia power after Monet's apparent death
we haven't seen a new snow snow user
appear quite yet one of the Marines
newest Admirals aramaki showed monstrous
strength with his Forest logia fruits he
dominated the remnants of kaido's crew
and also held the scabbards at Bay until
interference from Shanks with his fruit
he can fly long distances on a flower
sap the strength from opponents and
summon a practical Army of plans to
fight for him which now brings us to the
paramecia category of devil fruits that
includes well everything else this is a
mixed bag of powers that are left up to
Oda sensei's imagination but usually
fall into two types of categories there
are paramecias which manipulate the
user's body in some way or paramecia
fruits that manipulate the environment
or other people in some way starting
with buggy who was the very first devil
fruit user that we met in the series
beside Luffy and now that we know that
Luffy actually has a mythical Zone fruit
buggy is technically the very first
paramecia user that we ever get to meet
his chop chop fruit allows him to
disassemble his body at will this makes
him immune to cutting attacks his
separated body parts are also able to
fly provided that his feet are staying
on the grounds the sube subenomi Makes
avida's Body extremely smooth and
slippery attacks simply slide off of
this Ally of buggies Mr five of Baroque
Works can turn any part of his body into
a bomb he usually uses boogers but for
an advanced technique he can also
breathe into the chambers of a revolver
for long distance explosive shots Miss
Valentine can use her kilo kilo fruit to
alter her own weight for up to 10 000
kilograms she can make herself
lightweight to float in the air on her
umbrella or increase her weight to dive
bomb on opponents next we have a straw
hat make
while being named The Flower fruit
doesn't have much to do with the actual
flower instead she blooms or blossoms
parts of her body anywhere she chooses
to so pre-time skip she'd usually Sprout
arms on her opponents and break their
backs with her clutch technique however
after the time skip she's demonstrated
the ability to create clones of herself
make giant Limbs and even undergo her
demonia transformation Mr three or
galdino uses the wax wax fruit to
generate huge quantities of wax the most
utility that this has seen in the series
is through making keys as well as making
Venom resistant armor for Luffy during
impot down now WAP hold fruit is pretty
weird the Munch Munch fruit allows him
to eat anything and then incorporate the
material into his own body he does this
with stone and metal to fortify himself
and more horrifyingly eats his own
subordinates to combine them into one
super henchman Mr two's copy ability
allows him to transform his appearance
into to that of anyone that he's touched
with his right hand making him a master
of deception at the same time Mr one
uses his dice dice fruit to turn any
part of his body into blades this of
course made him the perfect opponent for
Zorro who had to learn how to cut steel
in order to defeat as bones Miss Double
finger Spike spike fruit allows sharp
spikes to protrude from any part of her
body iron cage hina's epithet is very
fitting as well her Ori orino me or bind
Pine fruit lets her conjure black iron
bars to trap criminals Bellamy's spring
spring fruit allows him to turn his
limbs into Springs which gives him the
ability to bounce super quickly around
the battlefields though flamingo's
string string fruit is one of the most
versatile devil fruits we've seen in the
entire series doflamingo is an example
of a character who truly mastered his
devil fruit Powers he could use his
strings to manipulate people like
puppets to create clones for himself to
stitch up injuries to his internal
organs and that is just the start of it
because this is not getting into super
op techniques like the bird cage in
addition the Ito etonomi was the first
example we saw of a paramecia fruit
Awakening which allowed doflamingo to
turn his environment into Strings as
well Foxy's noro noronomi allowed him to
fire a beam that slows down anything it
touches which even though looked goofy
actually kinda powerful Bruno of zp9 is
able to make a door on any surface and
escape to a sort of pocket Dimension
this of course makes him a great asset
as a Cypher pole agent as he's easily
able to get around undetected and flee a
scene unnoticed Khalifa another agent of
cp9 was given a bubble devil fruit by
spandom that among other things can make
her opponents extra squeaky clean
Captain very goods berry fruit can turn
him into balls Captain shoes rust fruit
can cause metallic items to rust very
quickly to the detriment of zoro's sword
and Captain shooting guru's wields fruit
lets him turn his arms and legs into
Wheels we also have pirona's hollow
olive fruit that allows her to summon
ghosts called negative Hollows which
make anyone they pass through negative
plus she can also leave her body to
float around in her spirit form which is
very convenient kind of similar to that
Brook's revive fruit brought him back to
life as a skeleton after his death for a
long time that seemed to be its only
power but now he's gained the power to
manipulate his soul the soul of others
and summon ice powers from the depth of
Hell which pretty badass and sticking
with the spooky theme the former warlord
gekkomoria used his shadow shadow fruit
to separate people's Shadows from their
bodies and then place them inside
zombies that are under his control the
clear clear fruit that was first owned
by Absalon and now by shiriyu allows the
user to turn invisible and Bartholomew
kumas nikuni kunomi or Papa fruit allows
him to repel anything whether that's an
attack a person or even an intangible
concept like pain and he can then use it
to transmit people at high speeds all
the worlds Luffy's rival used as kit
meanwhile has the power of magnetism
allowing him to manipulate any type of
metal for example after losing his arm
he uses his fruit to create a metallic
replacement with his devil fruit
Awakening he can also make his opponents
magnetic as well and Luffy's other rival
Trafalgar law has the ope open on me
which lets him create a room in which he
can then manipulate just about anything
he can remove people's body parts their
hearts swap their personalities trade
places with objects and attack opponents
internally this fruit also has a special
ability to Grant someone
eternal life at the cost of the user's
life with the so-called immortality
surgery meanwhile Capone beige's Castle
fruit turns him into a Castleman he can
shrink down his entire crew who can then
act as an army inside of him as well as
transform into a full-size castle with
tank treads basil Hawk and straw straw
fruit lets him use straw creatures as
voodoo dolls connected to other other
people's life force allowing Damage Done
to himself to be inflicted on other
targets at the same time scratchman
abused tone-tone fruit has the power to
transform his body parts into musical
instruments anyone who can hear his
music can be harmed by his sound waves
then we have boa Hancock's love love
fruit which allows her to turn anyone
who's attracted to her into stone one of
the most badass paramecia fruits is
probably that of former Warden of impel
down Magellan who has the venom venom
fruit which is a super interesting
paramecia it's very similar to a logia
that he can conjure seemingly Limitless
amounts of toxic goo but she can't turn
himself into it it does have a terrible
side effect too though of giving him
terrible stomach problems staying in
imple down Emporio ivankov's hormone
devil fruit allows them to use hormones
to do all sorts of things really the
most common usages of this route are to
change their own sex or that of others
or give an adrenaline boost to those
that need it so they can overcome
fatigue and keep fighting Inazuma also
from the Revolutionary Army has the snip
snip fruit that allows them to transform
their arms into scissors that can
basically cause anything oh and then we
have the Quake Quake fruit first owned
by Whitebeard and then Blackbeard which
is said to be a fruit with the power to
destroy the world because this fruit
creates powerful earthquakes but its
power can also be used locally to the
user's fist for an earth-shattering
punch josu earned his nickname with his
devil fruit which allows him to turn his
entire body into diamonds and another
white bit Ally who only appeared very
briefly blamenco uses a pocket pocket
fruit to develop pockets all across his
body on the Marine side vice admiral
turu has one of the weirdest devil
fruits in the entire series her wash
wash fruit allows her to literally clean
evil away from someone so she can wash
her opponents leave them out to dry and
people affected by her ability fold like
clothing and get strung up on a
clothesline next we have Shiki the
Golden Lion who may not have appeared in
the one piece timeline so far but he and
his fruit are both Canon despite mostly
appearing in the movie's strong work his
fua fuanomi allows him to levitate
himself as well as any other non-living
object at the same time the Fishman
Thunder Deccan also has a peculiar devil
fruit as well his Mark Mark fruit allows
him to Mark someone with his hands and
from that point on any object that he
touches or throws with that hand will
seek the target until it hits them or an
obstacle kind of scary kinemon's guard
Corp meanwhile is a lot more fun it
allows him to make clothing it's pretty
much perfect for disguising people
however it would be nice if he had
people to disguise who would last more
than 5 minutes without blowing their
cover oh yeah sugar this doflamingo
family member has by far one of the most
broken and op fruits in the entire
series you see sugar can turn anyone she
touches into a living toy with her hobby
hobby fruits she can then create a
contract with this toy that they are
powerless to disobey and finally and
this is where it gets op and also kind
of scary everyone immediately forgets
that the person turned into a toy ever
existed in the first place baby 5
another doflamingo family member can
turn any part of her body into any
weapon she chooses with her arm's arms
fruits presumably because turning them
into actual arms was already taken by
Robin Buffalo spin spin fruit allows him
to spin any part of his body like a
propeller which he then uses to fly and
as you'll notice we're really just
getting started on the Don Quixote
family fruits as well his crew has a lot
of devil fruit users treble the grossest
character in one piece I think is such a
low quality individual that his devil
fruit name in Japanese is literally the
beta beta Nomi this translates literally
into the sticky sticky fruit which
produces massive quantities of this
sticky muckus he can use it as
projectiles and even worse a cloak made
out of it to give the appearance of a
much larger person than he actually is
and this Marcus is also extremely
flammable next up we have Admiral
fujitora who has a gravity devil fruit
powerful enough to rain down meteors on
his opponents bartolomeo can cross his
fingers to create powerful barriers
which he can also send flying for an
offensive assault as well he can also
manipulate the shapes of this barrier to
create things such as staircases or
surround his fist with it for an extra
Hard Punch Leo from the totadas has the
stitch stitch fruit which allows him to
sob just about anything Viola's glare
glare fruit allows her to see amazing
distances and even through wall and
quite confusingly she can also fire
giant projectile whales from her eyes
jola's art fruit lets her transform
things into works of art often her Works
will resemble famous art pieces from The
Real World such as Brooke turning into
Edward munchus the scream oh yeah and
the jacket jacket fruit is one of the
weirdest and probably worst fruits in
the entire series because it allows
someone to literally wear the user like
a jacket at which point the user can
then pilot their body which gladius's
pop-up fruit allows him to expand and
rupture any part of his body in an
explosion which leaves himself unheart
it can also cause inorganic objects he
touches to explode as well now his power
is very similar to the bonbon fruit with
some minor differences send your pink
the most hard-boiled member of the
doflamingo family uses the swim swim
fruit to swim through matter as if it
were water interestingly enough this
power is now used by the seraphim
modeled after jimbei and speaking of
power is very similar to those of the
Baroque work members the Taunton fruit
is extremely similar to miss Valentine's
kilo kilo fruit the only difference here
is it can increase its weight far beyond
Miss Valentine's 10 000 kilo limits
another executive of the donkey show
Family Diamante uses the Ripple Ripple
fruit to make any object or himself
Ripple like a flack meanwhile Pika uses
the stone stone fruit to melt his body
into any stone structure and manipulate
it freely depending on how much Stone he
has available he can basically become an
entire Island absolutely massive hiding
his real body within the stone and so
during those Rosa he uses this power to
dramatically shift the landscape of an
entire Island as well and next we have a
very op fruit because kanjaro's brush
brush fruit allows anything he draws to
come to life
you were a real one doflamingo's brother
rosinante has the Nagi naginomi or the
kamkom fruit this allows him to create a
bubble of complete silence where nothing
can be heard now this seems like it
wouldn't have much utility but as lost
flashback showed us it can be fantastic
for stealth and the ability of the
tontada princess Mon Cheri the heel Hill
fruit is one of the only powers in the
entire story that can actually heal any
physical injury then we have big mom's
soul fruit that has to be one of the
most intriguing fruits in the entire
series with it she can cut parts of a
soul into an inanimate object to bring
it to Life as a so-called homie and she
can not only do that for herself but
also for other people so the citizens of
her kingdom willingly give part of their
lifespan to her in exchange for the
yonko's protection but she can also take
it forcefully from anyone who's afraid
of her meanwhile brelay's mirror fruit
lets her travel through a mirror World a
sort of parallel Dimension that connects
seemingly to every mirror in the world
other people can also travel into the
mirror World provided that they're
touching brulay she can also use her
mirror powers to turn into a mirror
image of an opponent as well as to
reflect attacks perrospero big mom's
eldest son uses his candy fruit to
create and manipulate candy into any
shape he desires can be a gooey and
syrupy one or it can be hardened next
cracker one of big mom's sweet
commanders uses his biscuit fruit to
create super hard biscuit soldiers he
can control an entire Army of them as
well as wear them as armor galette's
butterfruit well you guessed it lets her
conjure and manipulate butter mondor is
one of the rare big mom crew members
whose power doesn't involve food by the
way his bakubakunomi allows him to
control books and this manifests in a
lot of different ways it can fly by
standing on floating books but he can
also trap enemies inside story-based
Illusions as well as imprison and
preserve people and objects within the
pages of his books and now we come back
to all the food Opera's fruit is a lot
like galatz but with cream instead of
butter smoothie another sweet Commander
has the ring ring fruit which allows her
to juice just about anything including
giraffes puddings allows her to freely
manipulate memories when she uses her
powers people's memories will appear
like film reels which she can then cut
and edits katakuri of course made the
perfect opponent for Luffy during whole
cake Island because his Mochi fruit
shares a lot of similarities to rubber
Mochi too is stretchy but it could also
do a whole lot of things that Luffy's
body couldn't since he was able to
generate large quantities of Mochi and
unlike other paramecias karakuri can
also change his body into Mochi making
his fruit a special paramecia one with
the properties of a logia fruit the key
difference here seems to be that Mochi
is a man-made object rather than a
naturally occurring element really knife
or Puff Puff fruit lets him rub his
tummy to summon a powerful hellbird
wielding Genie to fight for his
Charlotte oven uses his heat heat fruit
to heat up his own body through touch he
can then transfer the heat to opponents
or objects just like aokiji often has
one of those rare fruits that have been
seen to directly affect the sea when he
boiled part of the ocean to attack the
sun Pirates stroizon ate the cuckoo
fruit and is able to turn any inanimate
object into edible Foods Charlotte noshi
can combine with his siblings using his
fuse fruit which now brings us to the
Revolutionary Army now morally of the
revolutionaries uses the ushi oshinomi
or push push fruit to push or mold the
ground as if it were made of clay Bello
Betty's pum pum fruit encourages and
rallies other people to awaken their
full potential to fight a perfect power
for a revolutionary and we're already at
wano otamas kibikibi Nomi allows her to
pull Dango from her cheeks and when she
feeds that to an animal they make that
animal completely loyal to tama's
command for one month this power notably
also works on smile devil fruit users
this power is largely inspired by the
Momo huddle myth of course wherein the
hero feeds kibi Dango to three animals
that then help him on his quest kuzuki
Odin's wife Toki traveled to the present
day from the void Century using the
powers of her time time fruit this
incredibly powerful devil fruit allows
her to travel in time but only forward
into the future and most importantly she
can also send other people into the
future as well shinobos ripe ripe fruit
allows her to age objects or even people
such as with momonosuke however she's
unable to reverse that effect Rizal the
ninja uses his scroll scroll fruit to
contain matter or energy within a scroll
and then release it at will it has been
seen to do this with huge amount of
water and even kaido's burro breath and
then Blackbeard's crewmates recently
have revealed some very new devil fruit
Powers too however not much is known
about their full capabilities just yet
Jesus Burgess muscle fruit seems to give
him immense physical strength we see him
lifting an entire Mountain Blackbeard
sniper found auger can use the warp warp
fruits to teleport himself or other
objects doc Q uses a disease fruit to
spread illness or in the hard Pirate's
case to spread Mass sex changes due to a
pun on the words malady and Milady get
it and the most recent devil fruit
revealed as of this writing is
vegapung's brain fruit which lets him
store an unlimited amount of knowledge
inside of an ever-growing brain in fact
his brain has grown so large that he had
to house it outside of his body however
we're still not dumb because there are a
handful of powers that we know come from
devil fruits but we still haven't gotten
confirmation on the fruit's name for
example jewelry Bonnie's fruit allows
her to manipulate the ages of herself
and others and I mean we're likely to
get a reveal for her food very very soon
another Supernova rooch uses an unnamed
devil fruit to convert physical damage
on himself into raw strength senjo and
wolf a giant of Blackbeard's crew has a
fruit that seems to grow his body's eyes
even more than it already has and
Lafitte also has an unknown devil fruit
that is likely the source of his wings
karasu the Revolutionary also has an
unnamed devil fruit because unlike a
Zone transformation that allows him to
turn into one big Raven he can turn into
an entire flock of ravens that can also
be separated and communicate and then we
have utta unlike other one piece movie
characters like gold to sorrow or
Douglas bullet utta has been confirmed
as a Canon character well sort of and
that includes her devil fruit them the
sing-sing fruit using her voice UTA can
lull people asleep and bring them into
an illusory world that is under her
control incredibly op and there you have
it all 146 devil fruits featured in one
piece so far but if you want to know
which devil fruits are actually the best
ones well you can check out this video
right here